hey guys back in Roseanne's
kitchen-table what are we doing here
there's an annotation right around here
to find out
I'm with Jaclyn Glenn and I wanted to
talk about something not controversial
at all
not at all feminism that brings out the
best in people afterward would you say
that the reactions are so different
totally different well I thought a nice
way to start a conversation about
feminism would be with the actual
definition of the word feminism since it
seems to mean different things to
different people so feminism is the
advocacy of women's rights on the
grounds of political social and economic
equality to men so equality for men and
for women that's pretty good what a
concept
right does that seem crazy it escapes
most people yeah I mean it's something
that seems pretty common sense to me
people should be equal but unfortunately
feminism has taken this like weird turn
like modern modern feminism people just
associate it with like man hating you
know women who don't shave their armpits
and it's a very stereotypical which is
kind of unfortunate
I don't yeah it's kind of I know we did
something on men anism which is the this
group of guys that now feel like they're
being you know pushed down and they're
not their rights are being trampled on
by the feminists and by all minority
groups and things like that but
generally it's been pretty good for men
I would say yeah basically right would
you identify as a feminist as a FET I
believe everyone absolutely should be
equal so I don't believe in Rashtra
right okay so that's but that's not what
I said yeah so would I say that I'm a
FEMINIST by that definition of feminism
yes at the core definition I feel like
everybody would be like hell yeah I
subscribe to that of course so most
people are good I am NOT a total [ __ ]
I think women should be equal right but
when you say that you're a feminist
today almost it has like a little bit of
a different meaning do you do you feel
that way so it has a different meaning
like you would want certain laws in
place to help women do better like
there's that thing about the pay
equality thing right look at Payless
yeah so a feminist maybe would want
those laws change
everyone should want that right see this
is what this is what gets me I don't
understand why we can't just be like
gender equality why does there need to
be feminism why you know why does there
need to be women's rights versus men's
rights why can't we just have like equal
rights rights well that's what I always
say about the gay thing like I don't
want extra rights
I just want equal right and guess what
the second I have equal rights I'll stop
talking right and I think pretty much
that's what women exactly - yeah but I
feel like a lot of feminists today go so
far into it right that they're like
almost putting men down right and
playing like social justice warriors
kind of thing they're fighting fights
that don't need to necessarily be fought
just like right so problems so we see
that all the time right right online
especially we see ones like fighting all
the time on their soapbox all the time
do you think that those feminists are
actually doing more damage to women
because they're actually creating a
situation where the guys yeah suddenly
you're on the defensive and then that's
what causes people exactly yeah I mean
it's kind of similar to like religious
extremists you know they make the whole
look bad but there's a difference there
because when it comes to religion the
extremists are actually more closely
following the doctrines that they're you
know given to believe whenever it's a
feminism they're like going over and
like making up [ __ ] that doesn't need to
have anything to do with gender rights
you know right okay I like today's
standards would you identify with the
group of people that call themselves
feminists it's hard to say like I
believe we're men should have equal
rights but they're right because we
don't want to subscribe to like the
nonsense that goes above and beyond so
right for me I'm hesitant to say I'm a
FEMINIST because of that like I don't
want to associate with that you know
right well that's how that's how I feel
related to the gay thing like as I said
like I want equality but when I see all
these organizations that oh they always
have to pick a fight because they're in
the business right of being oppressed
sorted so like you know as Chris Rock
says the cops need a certain amount of
crime and like if you're in the business
of you know being a minority group
it's a real problem because once you get
equal then all those jobs and all the
money dries up and all that so yeah I
want women to be equal I achieve and
this is that controversion no it's not
and that's the problem because like by
that definition we would both be Kelly
our feminist but like it's become so
warped but now we're hesitant to
subscribe or be a part of that group and
because of that people label you as an
anti-feminist and it's just like there's
no winning
are we feminists are we anti-feminist
let us know in the comments